and then code 8 Part 2 is going to be
effectively done and locked by the end
of this year code eight with your
brother yeah we did we filmed a second
one I didn't see the first one yet did
you not no well react with your brother
with my cousin yeah well brother cousin
people think we're brothers yeah yeah
they always say it's your brother yes
that's fine just Robbie yeah we have the
same last name how do you like working
with him
it's good
it's good is it weird that you're family
it is weird it gets it it we have and I
think that he would say that he would
say the same thing is we have different
we have a different process
um I wouldn't really know how to
describe our processes other than to say
looking from 30 000 feet they seem
different so we will have the occasional
moment of
butting heads a little bit right
but I think that's kind of because it's
it's family like you don't know always
where to blur the line between this is a
professional environment and we're
cousins and I played with you when you
were in diapers
right you just don't just don't totally
know and occasionally you know he's
super easy going
I like a schedule
and so something rolls off his back and
it hits me right in between the eyes
right right
that's just that's just the nature of
working with is there a competitive
thing no not at all not that you're
aware of not that I'm aware of no and I
don't I do not get that I do not get
that sense from him good at all you want
to make each other one of the one of the
one of the reasons that I look up to him
a lot I'm older but one of the reasons
why I look up to him a lot is just
because he
has the ability to
put a lot of passion into things but not
to take things too personally
right that's a good quality it's a
really great quality because you know
we're we're artists and when we're
slighted it's it's difficult for it not
to feel
like it's a very personal thing it's
often not and more often than not in
fact nine times out of ten it has
nothing to do with us it's not personal
but we take it personal anyways and I
learned from him
no just just just take a breath and
you know if you're in the right then
keep doing what you're doing and it'll
all come out in the wash so code eight
part two I think that's what it's going
to be called and you you filmed it yeah
it's done we filmed it last October
November December in Toronto
that's pretty sweet but it's a this
one's a big this one's a big Netflix
release really yeah the first one was
really a bet on ourselves
this one also in a different way we are
betting on ourselves I mean we took
we took some decent compensation but
anything that we took out wasn't going
on screen so
this movie was made for I think 20
million bucks wow and that's a that's a
big budget it is a big budget and I'd
like to think that
that if it comes out and it does the
type of numbers that it did that the
first one did on Netflix the first one
did incredibly well which is why Netflix
you know took on the property it's not
typical for Netflix to make something a
Netflix film when the first one was not
a Netflix right but if we can perform
really well for them at 20 million bucks
then I feel like they're gonna want us
to make four more of these things
that'll be pretty fun fine by me I want
to be on one of them that's if you do
three I gotta be in code eight part
three code eight part three I'm just
gonna go code nine code ten whatever